hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 5
video good old-fashioned Prison Break
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet I'll talk about the
really cool stuff that Stephen Amell was
posting today at the end of this
there weren't any crazy Easter eggs in
this episode it was just a continuation
of last week's episode they did
reference a lot of firestorm stuff that
happened during the flash so there's a
lot of like internal Easter eggs for
season 1 flash season 2 flash stuff so
I'll explain as we go along top 5 WTF
here we go cisco guest stars on the
flash only it's evil Cisco no wait he's
been drugged is Valentina Vostok
masquerading as mine Pallas Cisco
I love how diabolical she got to be in
this episode she was more fun than
Vandal Savage who is now like sporting
this crow Magnum hair look which I think
honors the origins of the character in
the comic books even though the TV show
has changed him to kind of intertwine
him with the Hawkman Hawkgirl origin
stories the super awesome STAR Labs
shout-out high-fives to Cisco I had
actually totally forgotten that he was
gonna get star and they were talking
about it this morning I didn't know what
it would look like given what is
happening on the flash right now were
the last two episodes I'm like is he
gonna have the energy to go help the
legends of tomorrow people but turns out
the explanation is that it's mine pal at
Cisco number 4 WTF not our first Prison
Break nice Easter Egg for that TV show
because of Captain cold and heat waves
characters they're actually doing a new
miniseries for that just in the same way
they did new x-files episodes with the
original cast that has absolutely
nothing to do with what's going on in
this episode that's just the writers
winking at you from behind the camera
onto my number 3 WTF Jax uses the Ronnie
Raymond trait to communicate with
firestorm if you don't remember the
flash season 1 Martin Stein was captured
by general Eiling in order to
communicate with them because of their
link Ronnie was able to carve a message
into his arm that showed up on Stein's
arms so that he could see that they were
coming to get him I also love the way he
casually shades Valentina Vostok with
the fall of communism as if it's Martin
Stein versus communism like hate to
break it to you 1991 things not going so
hot for the USSR and it was really cool
seeing valentina forced her way into the
matrix and after Stein forced his way
out and she turned blue if you remember
that happened to Martin Stein at the
beginning of season 1 after Ronnie died
he needed someone else to stabilize the
matrix that was why they went and found
jacks so they hadn't have found Jackson
time that same thing would have happened
to Marv
and sign he would have gone nuclear
number two WTF he waved in the Adam
team-up I totally love their scenes
together now heatwave actually respects
Rey he doesn't think he's a total
douchebag because he took that beating
for him but the fight in the prison yard
was so funny put your hand out then he
just swipes that guy's lighter and
stares at it while ray gets his ass beat
too bad he ended up spoiling rocky 4 for
that soviet torturer because this is
taking place in the 80s that movie isn't
too far off and finally my number one
WTF crash landing in Star City 2046
Stephen Amell was posting these pictures
from that episode that's next week's
episode he was posting these pictures
earlier today I didn't know if we get to
see it by the end of this episode but I
liked the way at the end of this week's
episode how they roll into next week's
episode with the WTF reveal of connor
hawke most of you guessed who this was
connor hawke on the TV show is just
someone who is inspired to pick up the
mantle of the green arrow after Oliver
Queen dies now because Stephen Amell was
posting pictures of himself facing
Deathstroke yes this is Deathstroke of
the future we'll have to talk about that
next week there's a whole bunch of
questions I have about them using that
character especially with what's going
on with Suicide Squad but just a couple
points of interest as you're scanning
around the rebel of Star City you look
up and you see that the Palmer tower
formerly the Queen industries tower is
now the smoke tower so we have to find
out what happened with that we have to
find out what happened to Oliver and his
van Dijk here what his role in this is
now like maybe he's gone to ground maybe
it's like a Batman Beyond situation
where he's still alive but he's
operating from the shadows and a younger
person steps up to take the mantle but
if you remember there been a couple
times during the show's run so far the
last couple of episodes that the legends
people have derped and changed the
future for the worse there was the
second episode and then there was the
firestorm WTF here's the 2016 looks like
with Soviet fire storms flying all over
the globe but less talking more drinking
let me know what your favorite part of
the episode was watching Valentina go
nuclear I'm gonna go ahead and take a
wild stab in the dark and say connor
hawke WTF at the end is probably
everyone's favorite moment but just a
reminder in case you guys didn't know
next week King freaking shark on the
flash Tuesday night Wednesday night is
going to be vixen on arrow Thursday
night is going to be this episode with
Connor Hawke and old Oliver Queen with
the van Dijk Revenge of the VanDyke it
looks like he's not quite as old as he
is during Frank Miller's dark
Knight Returns but that was one-armed
Oliver Queen he's gonna be one-armed
Oliver Queen in this episode I know it
doesn't look that way but it seems like
he has a bionic arm totally loving the
captain cold Canary thing they have
going on I love their scenes together
they have a nice energy the way heatwave
is baking some of the crazy into the
atom character of all the characters in
the show half of them are super crazy
the other half are super mellow I really
love when the crazy ones make the mellow
ones a little bit crazier definitely
felt like Victor Garber won the episode
in terms of acting if Captain Cold won
last week's episode just a mate amazing
performance from what Morris Miller then
Victor Garber won this week's episode
sorry honey you're just on the wrong
side of history so what I'm gonna do
next is a DC movie video it'll either be
Batman V Superman or Suicide Squad feel
free to leave any requests that you guys
want in the comments and actually that
reminds me congratulations to this
week's reverse-flash giveaway winner
zim sanders be sure to private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details so Suicide
Squad Batman V Superman stuff coming up
why guys wait for that stuff to post you
can click here for my air on flash
videos from this week and you can click
here to learn all about the Deadpool
sequel Deadpool on cable breaking the
tako space-time continuum thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight